sard says somewhere else hell is other
people
why is hell other people for start well
because other people are making choices
also
and when other people make choices
they
put some pressure on me
to think that the choice they made is
one that i should
uh copy or one that i should
sort of promote
but if i do it because they did it then
i'm in bad faith for sorry
so it's it is as if sart's view is like
we would be better if we were all alone
i mean this is this is really
simplifying starts position and this is
really just mostly start in a certain
period of his of his formation
but anyhow we can imagine that view and
i think there's something to the idea
that's art is attracted to it at least
in the mid 40s can you dig into hell as
other people is there some
obviously it's kind of a almost like a
literary like you push the point
strongly to really explore that point
but is there some sense in that other
people
ruin the experience so what it means to
be human
i think for start the phenomenon is this
like it's not just that you wear clothes
because people wear clothes in our
society like you have a particular style
you wear a particular kind of clothes
right and for sart like to have that
style authentically in good faith rather
than in bad faith
it has to come from you you have to make
the choice
but other people are making choices also
and like you're looking at their choices
and you're thinking that guy looks good
maybe i could try that one on and
if you try it on because you were
influenced by the fact that you thought
that guy was doing it well
then there's some important sense in
which although that's a resource for a
choice for you it's also acting in bad
faith
so
so god and god wouldn't do that right
god wouldn't be influenced by others
decisions and if that's the model then
that's i think that's the sense in which
he thinks hell is other people what do
you think parenting is then it's like
what because god doesn't have a parent
yeah so aren't we significantly
influenced first of all in the first few
years of life
and
even even the teenager is resisting
again learning through resistance
so absolutely i mean i think what you're
pushing on
is the
intuition that the ideal that starts
aiming at is a kind of
inhuman ideal i mean when we're there's
many ways in which we're not like the
traditional view of what god was
one is that
we're not self-generating we have
parents we
we're raised into
traditions and social norms and we're
raised into an understanding of what's
appropriate and inappropriate to do
and i think that's a deep intuition i
think that's exactly right
you